You've just finished your training as a Genetic
Counselor. Congratulations! And a new couple has come into
your office, interested in knowing the genetic risk
for their child, for a disease that runs in
both of their families. A pretty rare disease,
called von Willebrand's disease. Surprisingly, there's a member on
each side of the family that has Type3.
Which is characterized by a loss of the von
Willebrand factor. Which results in blood clot
defects much like those in hemophilia. Because
of your solid genetics trainings, you know
that the genetic allele that causes Type3
von Willebrand's disease is characterized by an
autosomal recessive allele. Here's the pedigree of
the couples' families. The male has a
father that's affected by Type3 von Willebrand's.
And the mother has a maternal grandmother that's affected.
Now based on the information from the following pedigree
and what you know about the genetics of Type3
von Willebrand's disease and the inheritance pattern. What would
you report to the parents, to the couple that's
interested in having a child? As the probability they
would have an affected child. I want you to
enter your response as a fraction in this box here,
a fraction where you have one number with a slash, a
forward slash over another number. I'm not going to give possible answers on
this, so it's going to make it a little difficult. See how you
do and see what it's like to be a real Genetic Counselor.